this morning on the dish husband and
wife team genevieve gurgis and ori
menasha
they first opened the hit italian
restaurant bestia then turned back to
their roots with a middle eastern spot
bevelle which was named best restaurant
in los angeles in 2019
two tries two hits and two people who
seem to have found a magic together
building a family and a food empire
we first tried profiling ori menasha and
genevieve gurgis early last year
but their story was put on the back
burner by the pandemic
italian restaurant bestia opened in 2012
and became an almost immediate hit in
downtown los angeles burgeoning arts
district
as customers flock to its dark and moody
look
shareable plates and trendy vibes
six years later gurgis and menasha swung
in an entirely different direction
with bevelle an aryan sun-soaked mecca
for middle eastern cuisine
which is where we found husband and wife
when we return to pick up our story
do you feel more comfortable now doing
middle eastern food or italian food
i feel the same about both i bounced
between two restaurants
it took a while to get that down oh for
sure it's uh
being obsessive and trying to
figure out how to create a food that is
in flavor very traditional but then
execute it in a more elevated way and
genevieve is it news to you that he's
obsessive
that's like the best word to describe
him ever
yeah i think i need to be obsessive to
perfect something
to her it comes very naturally she
doesn't need to be as obsessive
and it comes to her naturally and she's
able to do it so well
we're channeling he's scoring points
right now
bevell is the hebrew word for babel
harking back to the origin method
explains why people speak
different languages gurgis and menasha
were both born in the los angeles area
though menasha spent his formative years
in israel and traveled extensively in
south america
they met cooking together in an la
kitchen as a team
he does the appetizers and entrees she's
in charge of the desserts
they've strived to create something that
celebrates the universal language
of food i think that people put a lot of
emphasis on borders all the time as if
that is what's going to define
a cuisine is it has to be within this
border but
borders throughout history have changed
so much it's more about reaching over
and saying well
that looks amazing what you're doing is
amazing i want to incorporate that into
how i cook so yeah it's definitely
important
yeah and borders is what you know
gets people to be apart from each other
and we want to bring everyone together
at the dining room table in the middle
of bevelle
they unveiled for us a bit of what made
the los angeles times name this
the best restaurant in l.a in 2019.
olives marinated in cinnamon and citrus
served with sheep's milk feta oyster
mushroom
kebabs with a lavage and avocado puree
slow roasted lamb neck shawarma harissa
marinated grilled prawns
and a collection of dips to go with the
pita that menasha
has become famous for and i think that
bread
for this cuisine is probably the most
important
component you eat with your hands and
that becomes the vessel that
that you're basically feeding yourself
with this bread like it floats on air
i agree right i agree to complement the
restaurant
menusha and gurgis just released a
gorgeous new cookbook
which celebrates their modern obsession
with ancient food
a love letter to family including their
daughter saffron
and flavor profiles of the middle east
though like the restaurant
it truly has more of a global feel i
remember loving this last time
and if it's possible it's even better
now because the sauces are a little
different from
and that's that's the obsessiveness oh
this is
this is hence you get inspiration
from all over the place all your travels
you get more inspiration i think from
from going to mexico then you from going
to the middle east i think the idea is
not to get influenced by
flavors it's more like for me getting
influenced by techniques this avocado
cream is like a dance party in your
mouth
yeah and that's that again that's uh
like
mexico city right there yeah it is as a
base
yeah but it has cardamom in there and
sumac so it has
that middle eastern flair to all of it
you're saving something special here for
the end of our meal
yes so i'm gonna bring some desserts
for you to try not one to be outdone
gurgis rolled out for the end of this
dish segment three spectacular
selections
i would suggest starting with the most
meltiest to the second meltiest
to the most stable okay blood orange and
orange blossom granita made with
yogurt sorbet raw almond praline and
pomegranate syrup
it's like i'm eating a garden for
dessert right i mean that's how good it
is
really good a strawberry and sumac sweet
cheese pastry with pistachio ice cream
and sheep's milk ricotta incredible that
one's my go-to for breakfast with coffee
so great breakfast yes and finally
apple prune cake in a date toffee sauce
and creme fraiche whipped cream what do
you want this place
and this food to leave people with
during this whole pandemic a universal
thing that everyone learned regardless
of their experiences
is to enjoy each day you don't know
what's going to happen you don't know if
you're going to be in lockdown you don't
know
where your health is going to go and i
really want people to come here
and not think about what's going on out
there and have a little
mini vacation here i want them to really
just have a really good time
enjoy the food and enjoy the company
they're with that's what i really want
delicious one takeaway here ice cream is
great for dessert
so are the nebuchadnezzar drinks which
are right in front of us right here
yeah uh so it's bourbon blue plum brandy
smoked ice and grapefruit this is
this is this is their take okay cheers
i was looking at that pistachio ice
cream so this bourbon
is infused with lamb fats
oh tasty lamb fat lamb fat oh gee thanks
for telling me now